[Music]
good morning everybody uh welcome to
everybody in the room here at the
meeting
and those who may have joined us on
charity's youtube site
welcome to the plans committee meeting
of the 10th of march
um before we go any further i'll ask the
plans committee to introduce themselves
and then the officers are present in the
room for the meeting this morning i'll
start with myself and councillor chris
leather and i represent northward
morning my name is peter christie i
represent benefit
good morning my name is pete watson i
represent broady
good morning my name is rosie lot i
represent two rivers and three balls
[Music]
good morning
good morning richard i represent
hello richard wiseman i represent the
chevron elantra award
good morning my name is david
and i represent lutheran law
that's the committee in our starting
over there
one of the members sean harrington
planning
good morning manager stacie dorian head
of legal governance
and we've got good morning matt collins
county council highways
and we've got our two
star
[Music]
wars good morning sandra calls your
democratic services officer
good morning kirsty brown democratic
services officer lovely thank you
okay
apart from margarine
okay
um item one on the agenda's apologies
for absence well
i think we're all here everybody's here
this morning
item two on the agenda
is the minutes of the meeting held on
the 3rd of february on pages 5 to 12.
and i'll move those from the chair
counselor watson second again
can we take the votes on those pieces
[Music]
abstain
interest to declare should refer to the
agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interests when the item is being
considered
elected members of devon county council
town and parish councils
who have
considered a planning application
by virtue of the membership of that
council called a personal interest
and are deemed to have considered the
application separately
and the express views of that council do
not find the members concerned who
consider the application afresh
and item four of the agenda is
agreements between parts four and two
there is no part two on the agenda
urgent classes
gender items diversion matters
information brought forward by
permission of the chairman like no
urgent matters
six is public participation
we have got requests to join the meeting
from the members of the public so the
first application we've had
which is the land of cleveland we've had
mr andrew hockridge
speak to speak against the application
jonathan chick in support was the agent
uh for the industrial estate or the
bloodworthy one who got sue lander to
speak against amendment who is a member
of the public
and also to speak to that is ward member
councillor dart
for the
laurels in petruk still application
there's john gower to speak in support
of his agent agent
and for the west villa chillsworthy
hallsworthy one we've got jordy harris
to support peaking support who's the
applicant
and councillor kate heppell to speak as
a board member
okay
item seven on the agenda is planning
applications
the information
recommendations and advice contained
in the reports are correct
as of the day of preparation which is
more than 10 days
in advance of the committee meeting
due to these time constraints
any changes or necessary updates to the
reports will be provided in writing
or orally at the committee meeting
keeping that in mind
our first application was 7a but i'll
bring in the planning manager with
information on that one
uh thank you chair um well there's an
update to major updates in relation to
this application and unexpectedly
unexpectedly an updated noise control
scheme
and additional scheme
relating to asda's site which is
adjacent to their site was submitted
late valley applicants yesterday
afternoon late yesterday afternoon
whilst the reports indicate scheme is
acceptable subject to mitigation
your planning officers and the
environmental protection officer
along with committee members and members
of the public have been given limited
opportunity to scrutinize these
documents
your officers therefore recommend that
the application is deferred into a later
plans committee
[Music]
[Music]
for pencil in the glove or
council of watson
councillor wise man
your name is chair
thank you sandra
so in that case we move on to
application
7b
laura davis is here to give that
presentation
alright
[Music]
and associated works
[Music]
the settlement boundary and goes around
the application sites
like this within the sacramento boundary
as identified as proposals maps and also
includes the class of landings in the
north
and the
so there's also a highway that wraps
around the site made my lanes of
bradworthy which goes from the
southwestern corner and wrapped around
the northern part of the site to the
east
london road industrial estates you'll
see on the aerial photograph there
is to the south west and then you've got
dwellings at lower meadow to the south
and
there's a new barn which are to the
north eastern corner and then some
agricultural buildings as well
laura could you speak straight into the
end of that bring
[Music]
to help members and consider the ones
that you saw in the insight visit so
this
[Music]
and then view towards the existing
dwelling lower
[Music]
and then a view taken from the existing
uh fieldgate entrance so this is looking
from the southwestern corner of the site
across the eastern boundary
and the existing site is in agricultural
use it's fairly
flat and level
we've got hedgerows which run around the
outside with some mature trees and then
the distance there you can see
um on the opposite side on the eastern
side of the application
[Music]
from the existing site entrance to the
north so looking out along the highway
again
[Music]
will be kept
and then this is um
view south from the existing site
engines going back towards uh property's
lower bedo so to pan around a little
further you'll be able to see another
measure itself
which is just going there the boundary
isn't actually the hedge back there it's
actually a posterior
[Music]
and then views back towards the existing
sites entrance and see mature hedge back
on the other side of the road there
which forms the main boundary of the
site on the highway
and then these looking north
around the boundaries of the site
and then these views taken from me
immediately on the north
of the site so across the adjacent part
of the land which isn't in the
application site you can do some
foreground there
and towards the application site gives
you an idea of the public well
[Music]
along the public highway down towards
the moon
the eastern side
of the site
and then views across from the eastern
part of the site towards the
agricultural buildings
on the left-hand side of the photograph
there
and then use back across the site from
the east and towards the southern
boundary you can see lower meadow there
in the distance
application
layout
so we've got a mix of detached and
terraced semi-detached
plants from the sites a mix of one two
three and four veteran properties
we have a new access being proposed from
the south
western corner um which is slightly to
the north of the existing field gate
venturing as a separate
pedestrian that access the amounts can
sit there as well
uh it's public open space it's proposed
to the southern
south southwestern corner there and
there's also some proposed northern
central part of
the site
the surface water and continuation based
and proposed to the north eastern form
of the site and also a fair water
pumping session which is highlighted in
the great depth
this shows the drainage layout and that
again indicates the
attenuation pond
which would provide for a one in 100
year events and then surface water is
then to be discharged and attenuated
into south brook which is an existing
water course to the north
[Music]
arrangement which
indicates quite clearly there's separate
pedestrian access into the site as well
as papers right down the side and
visibility
as men did is now including 70 meters in
the direction from the injection
and we've got a number of different
house types and elevations which we can
run through fairly swiftly
unless you have any specific queries and
it's a fairly traditional design
pictures and gaining features and a lot
of the dwellings predominantly render
to the elevations with brickwork
detailing and concrete dark kind of
concrete tiles to the
roof slopes
so just to run through the different
house types
i've got three bungalows being proposed
as part of the thirteenth
and then details of all the garages that
have been proposed not all of the
dwellings would have a garage
we've got some street scene elevations
and showing some varied house types
across the site
so moving on to the main planning
considerations and the principle of
developments number one
and as indicated to start the
presentation and
there is
the application site is within the
settlement boundaries of bradwell just
to make members clear the fact that
there was a previous planning commission
on the site
and for 28 dwellings which included the
application site and the air into the
north
that was extant at the time we received
this application you'll notice it's a
2020 application and it has since
collapsed
so
this has been considered on the basis of
the application site and without the
full back position of the expansion
because it's no longer expanded so it's
been considered as an application for 38
but within the settlement boundary of
broadway so taking into consideration
the provisions of policy sta7 and a
spatial strategy for graduate
policy brd and the officers consider
that in the course of place policies and
the principles will be acceptable
number two the affordable housing and
if there was a policy compliance scheme
for the 38 dwellings we'd be looking
11.8 affordable units on site
and the applicants submitted a liability
assessment
and that took into consideration the
education contributions that were
requested by the county council
and the nhs contributions
along with the affordable housing
this was independently assessed by the
district valuer and has been subject to
some ongoing negotiations with the
applicant
the district valuer concluded in their
final report that a policy compliance
scheme would not be viable when
including the education and the nhs
contributions along with all the
affordable housing
the district value and then understood
some sensitivity testing and to
ascertain the point at which development
became viable and how much affordable
housing could be provided
and this is indicated to be 18
or seven units
i think you've had appended to your
report and the district values final
reports on that
and in terms of number three the housing
mix uh development looking through the
mix of one two three and four version
units
and the actually
a separate statement which justifies
some minor alterations to the
proportions that we would normally look
for from the council's headline and sort
of justifying the need to provide more
two-bedroom dwellings to meet local
needs
uh and on that basis and
the proportions are broadly in
accordance with the proportions in the
hedner uh your officers consider that
the development would have caught with
policy st 17.
we have put a condition on a
recommendation to secure the housing mix
and that's condition 16.
number four so the impact
landscape character appearance the
existing hedgerows
and trees to the main boundaries
adjacent to the public highway would be
contained as far as possible obviously
with the exception of the new access
point
and there are some existing hedge banks
who retain the other side
we've also had a tree protection plan to
confirm those details
the application site is an edge of
settlement location
you can see within most longer distances
we use the classroom surrounding the
built-up environment
settlement grad bradworthy
uh we've included a number of conditions
as part of the officer's report so it
deserves levels
for the development to be constructed as
condition seven
um a detail of landscaping plans
condition eight
and a landscaping environmental
management plans commission 10.
um
and
the mission include details of the
plants on the side of the boundary now
i'm not sure that's reflected actually
the wording that i've put in the report
so i would add in
there's a number of points that are
adding into conditions eight and ten
that i would add
also reflect specifically the planting
in the southern boundary
that reflects the recommendations of the
applicant's ldia
so
this
our
that
there's subject to those conditions and
it's considered to be keeping with both
since sc 14 and dm08k
and in terms of design
as i say it's predominantly two stories
in heights
heritage assets
the county council's archaeologist has
recommended the inclusion condition for
the written tv investigations that's
conditioned through that we've got in
front of you
in terms of residential amenities
we've had some amendments to the site
layout to make sure that
we've reduced the impact
on future future residents within the
development
and we've also put some
obscure glazing conditions on as well
just to limit any invisibility so that's
condition 20.
in terms of the existing surroundings
we've had
some initial concerns raised by the
environmental protection officer
about the relationship to the existing
industrial units and commercial units at
london road
as we've had additional noise
assessments and litigation measures and
the environmental protection officers
now has no objections but it's further
to the development being undertaken in
accordance with the recommendations of
the noise
impact assessment so that's also
included as a condition of the
recommendation
in relation to air quality
we had some initial concerns about the
relationship to the agricultural barn to
the east
and
we then had further comments from
environmental protection officers noting
the use of the building and its
restricted size so the chances of it
being used for intensive lifestyle
accommodation and limited
and its orientation with the openings
away from the application site
and he's also recommended additional
landscaping
boundaries between the two and his final
comments and note that there wouldn't be
a significant detrimental impact on
future occupants
and access and parking and we've made
some amendments to terms of the access
as part of the discussions through the
application process
um including a previously proposed
footpath to the northeastern corner
recommendation of the high-res officer
and the county council's hiring officer
has now raised no objections to the
proposed parking
[Music]
the county council's flood risk
management officers have recommended a
condition for the surface of exchange
for more details
as condition before
in terms of ecology we've got the
landscaping ecological management plan
which is condition 10
and also condition 17 which seeks to
ensure the department's undertaking
in accordance with the conclusions and
recommendations of the ecological
appraisal that's been submitted
and that includes
items such as reducing external lighting
and retention of existing habitat
features and provisioning additional
fattening boxes
in terms of biodiversity net gain we've
had a completed deparametric as we would
expect
and this indicates that there will be a
loss of
semi improved and marshy grassland from
the site
some hedgerow units for the access
and also some ditches from the site
and a small area of species which
grassland will be able to be provided on
site
particularly around the attenuation fund
however the applicant and their
ecologists have indicated the majority
of the biodiversity net gain would
in this instance
we've had some conversations and
discussions with the north africa and
then
concluded that an off-site contribution
would be suitable in this incident
and they've indicated some appropriate
projects
which would provide the relevant
habitats that would be lost from the
application site
and
that contribution will be secured as
part of the section 106 agreement
and
we move on to the section 106 agreement
itself
[Music]
so we will include contributions towards
additional primary school infrastructure
at bradwell
primary school there and transported
secondary school at holden keynes
college of peoples and contributions
towards the nhs gp surgery in bradford
and seven affordable dwellings to be
secured on site
in terms of the biodiversity net gain
contribution this was agreed with the
applicant outside of any viability
discussions
so that contribution was not included
within the viability assessment i think
you can see that from the report you
have appended to your
your gender
and the final point for the section 106
is the provision of on-site public open
space to include quick face space
and so
proposed development is recommended for
approval such as the conditions outlined
in the offices report and the head to
terms of
section 2016.
thank you
thank
comprehensive presentation
our first speaking to this application
is um
a member of the public school number and
against the application
thinking when you settle we have three
minutes thank you to present to the
commission
thank you chair good morning
um as you all know the reasons i'm here
rather than again has too many houses
already planning um i said this before
many times
however the continued pressure of our
schools and doctors is in some way being
addressed by this application
but even when a 106 agreement is made
between the district council and the
applicant the district council has no
control over developers when they cite
that the application is still not
financially liable this is precisely
what they have succeeded in doing since
this application went into planning
there is no doubt that the office's time
and energy has been spent trying to
reach an agreement on the viability of
this scheme
but the parish that we represent remains
out of pocket
with regard to affordable housing whilst
the parish council acknowledges that the
agent worked within the district
valuation office we simply cannot
support an affordable housing offer of
18
in a rural local centre where the demand
for affordable housing is high and will
remain high
this is contrary to
18
policy
the adopted local plan
there is no point in having a local plan
if developers are allowed to question
the affordable housing contributions and
the planning department continues
to put these applications to your
committee with these low numbers of
affordable housing offered up as
acceptable
this is an unsatisfactory situation for
all of us
we and other parishes will continue to
question and challenge the common sense
of this approach if the site is
unbiasable simply reduce the price that
is being asked for it
do not pass that commercial viability
issue of councils
low carbon torridge there are no energy
conservation or alternative energy
measures within this development
this is contrary to st 05 of the local
plan why when torrid is working towards
becoming a no carbon council do these
houses not support green energy saving
at the biodiversity net gain the parish
council is concerned that nearly 124 000
of the 106 contributions from these
houses in our parishes going to a
project of amateur or rover and it's
being run supported by the northstone
biosphere we're shocked and angered by
this decision made with no consultation
within our parish
we were only informed of this two weeks
ago at no point were we consulted about
this or given time to offer up
alternative schemes
we have several identified projects that
would benefit from this huge sum of
money we are in dire need of a new
recreational area that could be a
sustainably led initiative we have
discussed the habitat project to regain
that wind nesting sites and also a
community orchard and a beehive scheme
it is completely unacceptable that we
get the houses but another area benefits
from such a huge sum of money which if
we were to have could create our own
green projects therefore we are
requesting that this application be
deferred so that potential biodiversity
projects in our parish could be explored
and discussed
thank you
thank you
our next speaker to this application is
councillor dart ward member
good morning thank you for allowing me
to speak
um
to begin i should simply state that i
absolutely concur with all the valid
objections and observations raised
within the report
and bradley parish council as usual
are bang on their assessment of this
application and indeed with the
requirements of their village and i
thank them for their commitment
comments raised online are all valid
concerns
which need appropriate weights applying
to them
i am here to raise my concerns over the
106 heads of terms
and the apparently incorrect statement
that there will be 11 affordable driving
which actually now reduced to seven
if indeed they ever come to fruition at
all
healthcare i've got no issues with that
public transport no issue education no
issue and play areas and public open
spaces open to negotiation but
the whopping amount of
123
490 pounds for off-site biodiversity net
gain for projects not in gravity
speaking frankly is the net gain cannot
be implemented within the site and the
offsetting cost is that amount
its common sense surely
do not build that amount of houses on
this site in the first place or just
don't build on this site
also
the fact that the viability assessment
as i understand it was done before the
biodiversity net gain calculation
not only will impact on the seven
affordable housing
because actually they couldn't afford
eleven
before
the hundred and twenty three thousand
four hundred and ninety thousands added
on
ultimately we'll end up with no
affordable houses on this site
many of you attended our joint local
plan consultation and workshops
one of the main priorities to come out
of that consultation
amongst us counsellors
was affordable housing for local people
not only
that our environment was also a priority
i say again if the impact of this
development is so considerable modify
the amount of houses on this site
um
[Music]
or just don't build it
there are a considerable amount of
material planning considerations that
have been raised
and are valid given that those
given those and the apparent impact on
nature within this site i would suggest
you simply do not grant this application
as it has been submitted
what we need is affordability for local
people and that is in the end not what
this site will provide
thank you councillors
right
laura gets back in position
yeah i mean i've listened very very to
what these speakers have said and i too
questioned why this was not a viable
proposition
um because they're building 38 houses on
a much smaller site than the original
application was between the eight houses
but then when you look at the 106
agreement for the original ones
they were
seven hundred 13
seventy five pound for education
um
and play equipment and ten thousand
maintenance of eight thousand now
they're on a smaller site but with more
units their primary education
contribution has gone up 147 000 and the
transport 14 898.
i would ask if the nhs contribution of
13 000. does that go direct to the
brightworthy surgery or would that be
lost in the nhs central pot
um it's been specifically requested by
the nhs and for bradworthy and they've
put a calculation of the fact their gp
surgery is over capacity currently and
what that additional contribution would
be able to generate so if they do
specifically
state that that's what they want the
money for and obviously that could be
secured by the wording in the section
106 to make sure it's but that can't be
paid to nhs director would not go to
grant worthy surgery well no he paid the
nhs but it would be worded in the legal
agreement that it would be for
the broadband i just get worried that it
will be lost in the holy thoughts of the
nhs and not eventually come to brainwood
i also want to mention the biodiversity
122 000
um because on page 69 it mentions
abortion cliffs
so i must assume that the rover is in my
ward
yes
i know there is a big um biodiversity
project going on i do agree with
councillor da and the speaker that you
know brad bernie should have had a
chance to put in their own biodiversity
plans
within surrounding their own village you
know i mean to come out to romero which
is many miles away i don't think really
sits well
but on the other hand um
i'm playing 54
devon county education quotes
and they base their figures on 36
dwellings and in fact the application is
for 38 dwellings so i'm wondering if
that was a misprint or whether they have
based their facts on the wrong number
and i can respond to you on if i can and
they only calculate family-sized
dwellings there are two one-bedroom
flats proposed so they wouldn't seek an
education contribution from the wrong
place like that
um
but looking on the positive side there's
no highway objections southwest water
but no objections and devon county flood
risk
risk assessment have got no objections
so before making my final conclusion i
will wait to see what my fellow
committee members are saying
thank you councillor cancer christian
yeah thank you um
yeah i read through this
great interest because
it is contentious as actually every
planning application does seem to be
today um i heard the brandworthy parish
councillor i think last time they came
they said there were 77 houses that had
planning permission they're not
bradworthy that hadn't been built this
is going to take it up to 115 and it is
getting quite ridiculous this and again
goes back to national legislation we
cannot force builders to build these
things
however having said that i've got a
couple of questions the first one
i noticed there is a foul pumping
station
on this side where does the sewage go
[Music]
where does it actually end up it ends up
in the bell the existing bouncer which
is to the
[Music]
some of us are getting extremely worried
about the carrying capacity of cornbread
and the fact that southwest water keeps
dumping sewage into our rivers and our
coastal waters this is why i'm going to
ask this question every time from now on
the second point is i
i looked at the affordable housing
and when i read through uh the papers
um what i
first read
which
uh
worried me
immensely
if you turn to um
page 95
this is the viability study
section 23 there comments and
recommendations
i have this is the
district value of speaking i have
concluded that based on the available
information the applicant's contention
that scheme as proposed cannot vibrate
provides required section 106 is correct
i disagree however with the original
contention affordable housing
contribution would need to be reduced to
nil
absolutely astonishing he didn't want to
build any
but the district value has gone back
he's done his viability studies but when
you read the viability study uh it's
already been pointed out by council a
lot that there were going to be more
houses
in the original plan where there were
fewer houses being built but i thought
the brandworthy parish council made it
extremely good point we've all made it
before we have a district plan
30
if they don't meet you don't build i've
said this before what i found
interesting was if you turn to page 88
hey gta look away from the bottom it
says grant funding
if you read the paragraphs above that
in addition to the on-site provision of
affordable housing
to accord with planning policy
requirements we're going to recycle
requiring off-site commuting some of 56
000 pounds to bring up to 30
i've never seen that before
i mean we've got an application out here
which is offering 5
does that mean we're going to get 25
we're going to get a lot of money from
this i've never seen that before i don't
know about the council
but it struck me it's really strange
that they're not meeting the 30 they're
going to give us money to make it up
where does that come from we've seen
that before
um as to the biodiversity thing
um
well
we've had this before haven't we
we had it at ecuador where suddenly we
found the biodiversity it was going to
be in my ward
first i'd heard of it nobody had asked
us and we do need to look at this very
carefully because it does seem
i don't want to upset matt collins but
it's this typical devon county thing you
know you give money to a road which is
miles away and it seems to be the same
sort of um proposal here and i would
query why it's going somewhere else
um
i mean first i've heard of biodiversity
schemes in absence
i'm not sure what that's about
but you know it does need to be looked
at and the other thing that did worry me
um was
the viability study
yet again
we don't know what's being paid for the
land
there's an average being taken
it's very low somebody's making a lot of
money yeah all the figures it looks very
technical
but it's not there
so help me make up our mind one other
thing
it was mentioned by our planning also
the noise i've got
i've got it on google earth here when
you look at google earth there are two
industrial units either side of the site
and they're not just they are
next to it and i see our planning
officer our environmental protections
were satisfied with the noise thing
that would have come up earlier today if
we discuss the other ones and i i do
wonder we these are industrial units
they're up and running
everyone who if these houses get built
if they buy them they have a statutory
right to complain
what happens when that our officer says
oh at the moment it doesn't matter
because there's no noisy things there
that can change we need to look at these
things and look into the future far more
than we seem to
thank you council christie
casablanca just to answer christopher's
question with regard to the sewer works
yeah that's the sewer plant it's
actually on the other side of it it's
like on the supplement side
and
for years as far as i know there's been
concerns about that being up to capacity
anyway capacity so there are you know
concerns about that anyway
so
just to let you know
[Music]
i think it's wrong that the
biodiversity gains should be elsewhere
and i think that we should defer this
and ask the parish council to come
forward
with alternative suggestions for the use
of the money i think when we're building
a development this should be the local
area that benefits from any benefits
from the development because they suffer
the detriment from the development so
i i do think that we need to look at
this again
thank you country
anybody else
well i've got
one queries on the
district valuers reports it's only
valued for three months
surprised me when i when i saw that
it does say validity period the report
will remain valid for three months
unless circumstances alter further
material information becomes a bit or
further material information comes
reliance should not be placed on the
viability conclusion beyond this period
without reference back to the voa print
update evaluation
now this is eight months ago this was
done and there's quite a few issues have
been raised to do with the
uh
validation
that the district values done
and i got
marked a few in here
um
the potential loss what they joined
right on page 89
i worked at the cost if you look on page
87 i'm sorry
86
and
the size of them on page 88 you've got
what they were valued at
in july
2021 now i prices of rock italian
nations have rocketed since
the summer of last year they really have
it in our area
and i just questioned
whether this
this should be really looked at and take
on board
while it's being looked at as well
some of the things that aren't in there
like some of the offset
which which was in i don't know if 106
has been signed or
so the points made by
the speaker about the biodiversity
offset i've got to agree
i'm getting fed up with this
being used as a a quick get out
somewhere because
[Music]
that's a to me that's the last
last option is offset and even if it's
used
and it can't be enhanced on site for me
it certainly should be an immediate area
um and certainly within the village like
bradwood
of the offset and not
a figure given again to
the buyers atmosphere reserve people to
spend wherever they went
on whatever they want
but it's the
viability report that i question looking
at the figures that
on pages 8 98 and 99 if you look at the
1998 that was when
link's proposed to have 11.
affordable
and then on the other page on april 99
that is with the 7th
looking through all the figures
the profit
is up actually but at the bottom they
make out but there's no profit at all
on the on the one with uh 11 affordable
it was showing the deficit of 268 000 on
the one where they reduced into seven
at the bottom it's your surplus deficit
nothing
not making a profit not making a deficit
and looking through some of these
figures i couldn't make them
i could not work them out
and i think we need a bit more clarity
particularly again having read through
that
that um
this report should be gone through again
because it's not valid according to
their own
district i mean after three months it's
not well they canceled this yeah
that but can i just ask one thing
um we've heard from the council of the
award member
was she actually part of the section 106
conversation no
not again look i am getting absolutely
fed up with this we keep asking this has
been passed by the council that every
section 106 will be discussed with ward
members before it comes to us
and i've just started council dart is
shaking their head
yeah
we work
through the chat
we were emailed as wall councillors
about
two weeks ago with the stipulation as to
what it was and that is why i'm here
today because
the shock of finding that out and in
fact not having to say
what i mean the
been proposed and secondly that is
deferred this is first
a re-evaluation
of the district values report which is
out of date in actual fact now
um and also
the sexual model six which hasn't been
signed
we
would like the board members involved in
whatever's in in the section 106
and this issue of the biodiversity
offset contribution 120
3 000 pounds an awful lot of money there
are other figures in here that i would
have
mentioned in the district valuers
assessment that i'm not happy with
and
it's been proposed and sent me to defer
it for further information on those
issues that have been raised
um
yeah if we may come back on some of the
points to see um the officers have to
have the opportunity to come back to
some points
and i think it's important that we do so
at this stage
now laura may want to add some things to
what i'm about to say is the case also
there's a detail of the application
um i think firstly in relation to
council christie's point about the
um additional 56 000 pound i think it
was on the affordable housing
that's due to as the case also mentioned
in the presentation that um thirty
percent equates to eleven point eight
and this is the point eight so you'd
seek in principle you see eleven four
housing on sites and the point eight is
a financial element and that's always
been saying that's another policy and
that happens all the time and that's
what comes when the money goes
sorry where does the money go then the
money comes to college council
and it's listed as an affordable
contribution for them to go to an
affordable housing scheme elsewhere in
paris or district depending on why they
councillors would like that
and we've got some monies in northern
west hill for example at the moment
so that's the commuted stun first i've
ever heard that thank you
i'm sure sean penn just into check there
that was only 11.8 that was proposed
originally that's right
this has dropped back to seven now so
where's the point
so in the if you read the district
values report he goes through what would
be a policy policy
and that was a policy combined scheme
would be eleven one eight
so if it's seven if it's a full number
there's no community seven because
that's provided seven so the 56 000
would drop out yes yeah yeah because
that was based on the policies
um in relation to biodiversity net gain
um
this is a interesting interesting
subject um because as you'll be aware
our local plan was a bit of a leader in
relation to biodiversity in that game um
and it allows for offsetting within the
plan
off-site offsite and that is um
and it's something that gets the support
of the environment agency
i would also raise the environment act
2021 um which will
assume going through
and which requires nationally for
district councils to have this
biodiversity
10 net gain which isn't in case the
moment is just us
but as part of the environment act that
also advocates off-site
net gain
and it will also allow for applicants to
give that money to the secretary of
state to spend that somewhere nationally
so that's coming in the environment act
2021 so somehow members need to be aware
of we are very fortunate within torridge
and northern
you can act as a broker for off-site net
gain and members will be seeing this
more and more coming forward um and we
would say we're very fortunate that
we've got the biosphere and that
wouldn't go then nationally to secretary
of state which is an option for
applicants in the future so it's just
something members need to be aware of
um
is there anything else that you'd like
to pick up on if i can just add in a bit
about why
the projects have been identified in
aberchem and in rover
we've as i set out in my presentation
there are some three separate points in
the biodiversity that have been lost in
the types of habitat that are being lost
on site so we're losing some hedgerows
we're losing some grassland and we're
losing some ditches
so the conversation we've had with the
biosphere is that we're looking to
offset those particular habitats and
provide those elsewhere
and it happens that they have
costed projects in place for aperture
cliffs for
majority of it but i think they also had
the option of potentially some of the
money going to a project that they had
in brokerage but it was to address those
specific habitat types
thanks laura
another issue on the section 106
is this about the health contribution
there was already on page 68 third
paragraph 10
within the
the section model says the nhn test gap
section
the section 106 department note in the
gp survey in brad where there's already
over capacity
within its existing footprint and
therefore the whole
local health care provision will require
a review
a contribution towards this has been
calculated so it's a contribution not
towards doing anything surgery
but to actually reviewing the health
provision
because i believe that
that needs a bit more clarification as
well
counselor
thank you
um right so the proposal in front of us
is to defer and that sounds nice and
simple doesn't it um i do i have a great
deal of sympathy with the idea of money
being raised from any potential
development being spent in the past of
course i do
but what happens
when no scheme is available to go for
i'm assuming we would run the risk of it
going out shortly
but going national from what we've just
been told but also your our suggestion
that the developmentally revalued by the
district value
we have seen the price of houses what
hugely in the last two years 20
something crazy
but that seems to be stagnating now what
we're what's happening now is that
inflation and building costs is going up
a great deal we very seriously run the
risk that these seven affordable houses
might end up
being
close to zero
when a revaluation is made it might be i
think it's quite
quite a risky suggestion that's been
proposed
right okay um that's anybody else
anything to
to speak on this application has been
[Music]
the issues that have been raised to be
clarified further and for the section
one and six
the ward members to have an input into
the section one and sixes as well which
is important
and
so samuel will you change them
i mean i've got difficulty with that i
mean
i would prefer it
sorry
i would defer it
purely on the question of the
biodiversity money i agree with council
wiseman once you start asking for more
viability balls we may run into trouble
and end up with nothing so i i can't
support a deferred on those two grounds
okay could you take the vote please
counselor that's sorry sound right
yeah thank you chair councillor
paul
councillor brown
thanks
for
councillor watson again cancer wiseman
that's six four chair and three against
thank you sandra
right we move on then now to
[Music]
7c
which is on pages 114.
okay and sarah boyle our planning
officers will present this one thank you
sarah good morning councillors
so the application for you is an outline
application with all matters reserved
for the conversion of two former arms
houses to two units of holiday
accommodation
near the logs in at petrol stove
just to give a bit of
context which has been put in the report
in front of you
and the application seeks outline
permission
um and is set out in the development
management procedure order an outline
planning permission is a permission for
the erection of a building which is
granted subject to a condition requiring
the subsequent approval of the local
planning authority with respect to one
or more reserved matters
the application has been accompanied by
a location plan block plan and
supporting statement
and the statement submitted details that
the proposed holiday units would be
within the footprint of
and fully the existing buildings at the
site
within the town of country planning
development management procedure order
part 3 article 5
section 2 notes
where the authority who are to determine
an application for outline planning
permission are of the opinion that in
the circumstances of the case the
application ought not to be considered
separately
from all or any of the reserved matches
the authority must within a period of
one month begin
beginning with the date of the receipt
of the application notify the applicant
that they are unable to determine it
unless further details are submitted and
specifying the further details
this was done within the first month of
the application
and the agent was emailed requesting
further details relating to access scale
appearance and layout
therefore the only matter reserved is
landscaping
and the application should be considered
on this basis
so this is the location plan for the
site so the site is in red
and the land owned by the applicant is
in blue
so towards the south
you've got um the section of arms houses
there and then
the red line does go up because there's
allocated parking which is within the
pub um parking area
there you go so the red kind of scoops
up around to the to the north so that's
where the parking is going to be um and
the arms houses are to the south and in
the middle there that is the lulls in
the public house
so this just gives you a context of the
list of buildings surrounding the site
so you've got the site outlined in
orange um
then to the west you've got the grade
two star church of st petroc
to the south you've got grade two
properties one and two church gates
then to the east you've got the grade
two war memorial which sits kind of
right in front of the arms houses and
then you've also on the east got that
line of grade two listed cottages and
then obviously further listed buildings
so just kind of give it a bit of a
context of the site
and surrounding heritage assets to the
site
so this is just to give you some kind of
photos
so this is looking southwards so if you
have a look on the west that is the line
of listed cottages and then you've got
the laurels in
public house there that access there
goes
round and that's where the parking has
been allocated as per the application
this slide is just showing you the north
section of the site which is linked to
the pub the novels
so you've got the um
two star church in the background
um so you can see that it is seen in the
setting of of that church
so this is just to give you a clearer
image from the road so you can see the
context of the site so you've got the
the church in the background which i
said it's great to start you've got the
war memorial there with the green area
in the forefront um and then you've got
the proposed site in in the middle of
the two linked linked to the laurels
this is just to give you a closer
section of the proposed site
this is looking south just to show you
in the context of the the distance
between the site and the wall memorial
to the east
and that's just the self elevation
showing you the context with it linked
to the novels
and then that's once again the south
elevation to the back to show you the
kind of that is the church gates right
next to the site um and then obviously
you've got the church and the graveyard
behind it
so this is just looking northwards again
just to show you from the other
direction so you've got the war memorial
the proposed site and the church
you've got listed building just there on
the corner
and you've got the logs in pub and then
obviously the road that continues
through petrol stone
this is just to show you a view from the
church graveyard so this
is the back of the novels and parts of
the
proposed sites
[Music]
and then that's just another view of the
proposed sites on from the graveyard
so this is the grade two star church
this is actually from the um
parking area of of the pub um so that is
part of
section of that access is part of the
the application
[Music]
and then that is the grade two listed
cottages which are are opposite the site
so this is what we've received um in
terms of the proposed site plan so as
you can see you've got the proposed
holiday units
and then garden immunity area to the
west which is between the site and the
boundary of the grade two star church
and then up to the north there you can
see the parking and highways access
which is um associated with the parking
for the pub
okay so that's that's the plans that we
have received um as stated at the
beginning of the presentation we did ask
for more information
due to the heritage assets that are
surrounding the site um we had a written
statement coming from the agent which
specified um a couple more details but a
lot of it was that this is an outline
commission um and they wish that to be
considered a reserve matters we have
three outstanding objection comments
from consultees so from the conservation
officer historic england and devon
county council
stating that there's insufficient
information um for the impact of the
change of use of the holiday units in
respect to those surrounding heritage
assets
the parish council have also commented
with concerns um and there is 14
objection comments on the application
so just going through the considerations
um we've outlined the application in
context
the principle of development as stated
in the report
we asked for for further detail um
to assess it in terms of
dm18 for tourism accommodation
there is the first three elements which
has stated in the report this is looking
at um
kind of a reuse of an existing building
however it does carry on in that policy
to say and in all cases it has to comply
with d to h and that is where it doesn't
comply because we have not got the
information that to make sure that it
does
identify and doesn't cause significant
harm on any of the heritage assets
so
we are
have three reviews and reasons
one is primarily on the appearance and
character and the principle of the
application in terms of the heritage
assets one is on the immunity because of
the lack of information insufficient
information and the third is
insufficient information on access and
parking
thank you sarah thank you for that and
you've got one speaker
to this application
um
on gara
who's the agent for the application
thank you very much thank you when you
settle your three-minute stream yeah
thank you thank you thank you thank you
very much for taking the time
[Music]
on the application um
the
there's two sort of small storage units
they're not in a derelict state but they
are in a deteriorating material state
and they're not really
used
um the local plan policy supports the
reuse of these buildings
we appreciate what's said by the officer
about the um
the need to comply with all the relevant
um
uh
concerns about
impact on heritage assets in the village
but as we've highlighted in the
application itself this is an outline
application
we
totally understand and respect the fact
that within one month we were asked for
additional information the lpa of course
has the right to ask for that extra
information that doesn't mean it's not
an outline with all matters reserved
application anymore that just means
there was extra information they
requested
we provided
extra information on each of the points
raised
without trying to stray into
coming outside of the bounds of an
outline application there is no scheme
before the council here there's just a
principle
the outline application seeks the reuse
of these for an economic reuse for
holiday
it will allow the buildings to be
restored conserved and enhanced within
the streets
really the question before the council
is
is there no scheme that could be put
forward at a detailed application stage
that would be acceptable and we think
that's
not
not reasonable of course there is a
scheme but before that expense and
effort has gone to with an architect and
heritage statements we want to know is
the principle of the development
acceptable that's why we put in an
outline bank application
the owners of the property
got a formal pre-application
previously which told them the principal
agreement was acceptable
so they want to confirm that with an
outline application before then going
forward with a scheme that will show
materials design layout everything and
we'll have heritage statements attached
to it
if the council wants to set the bar very
very high
with that detailed scheme and say we
will only accept a scheme that ticks
this box this box in this box in terms
of heritage assets in terms of use in
terms of impact that's absolutely fine i
would
recommend that the council do so because
it's a lovely street
it deserves to be
preserved enhanced conserved um and i
would say the bar should be set very
hard in terms of what's acceptable when
a detailed steam is put forward
this isn't a detailed scheme this is
just an in-principle application
an outline application will manage to
deserve
buildings exist there is no plan for the
footprint to be extended in any way
there is no plan for the character of
the buildings to be changed
and there is ample parking because of
the public houses very large car park
so there wouldn't be any on-street
parking issues that's that's really as
far as we've gone at this stage
and so we commend to the council
that in line with the pre-application is
right to receive by the
owners of the property the principle of
development being agreed
and out like an outline application we
approve
and then
any conditions that need to be applied
to that can be
or
if the accounts can wait for a detailed
scheme to then be put forward and assess
it on its merits and if that's not
acceptable and it's felt that it has an
impact on unlisted buildings that's
unacceptable it should be reviewed and
that's absolutely
we'd respect that completely
thank you very much
[Music]
okay
all right this was called him back
cancer wise and so come to your life
oh thank you chair
um i did call it and you can see my
reason there
the questions i had at the time
when this application
came forward were that
it would have it could potentially have
some impacts
on the historical
um aspect of the village
i've read the report
and heard what's been said
this morning and those questions are
turning to concerns
clearly we have the statutory um
consultants consultees um have
objections haven't removed those
objections
um so i don't know where where we can go
with this really
apart from it's very simple it's only in
front of us apart from to agree with the
recommendations of the officer but i
would still be willing to uh hear what
anyone else has to say about it
thank you councillor wiseman
council
i i i totally agree with richard um
it's
i really enjoyed this report
i mean the officer states time and time
again that they haven't had the
information come back that they've asked
for
uh and
i'm a bit disappointed in that to be
quite honest that they've not come back
to do that
but
if richard is going to propose it i'll
second it shall we
yeah i mean i would just like to point
out um the comments from our own
conservation officer when she says
there's a little opportunity to raise
the roof without a harm in the setting i
mean if you took notice of the pictures
i don't know how on earth he would turn
that into a holiday accommodation
without
hiding in the you know the height of the
roof and then that would definitely have
an impact on the heritage
um
setting in the church and the great
guard at the wall memorial so i would go
along with refusing the application on
those grounds
thank you
come to christy
yeah well some of our holiday nets are
as small as that so i don't think that's
a problem um look at the asbestos roof i
mean they're not very good aren't they
but having said that i'm i ask one thing
i in patrick's those the parish
council's response we request that until
the application from the public house
has decided no decision made on this
application as the two applications are
interlinked
can i ask about that what's the idea to
turn these into holiday nets to support
the pub
or everyday now reads that the pub is
applying to stop it being the pub
so we've got another application at the
moment which is um
to change the pub into a dwelling
um we originally were going to bring
both together um because obviously
they're next to each other so we've um
we're still in discussions with the pub
to a dwelling we are requesting kind of
further information
um and looking out for evaluations we
spoke with the agent um and it was
requested that this one came forward
this one is completely independent of
that one this is changing to holiday
units so on their request
as a local authority we have brought
this one forward to committee with the
knowing that it was going to be refused
the other application is still in the
process of being determined
right
thank you that does actually cover my
view because you know a puff is a
community asset and this was going to
support it you'd see the reason if it's
just purely speculative holiday
development it does change the whole
place actually
for me
council wiseman did you want to come
back uh only just to say that yes an
answer to uh council watson that is my
proposal
i will move it and we refuse
[Music]
[Music]
the clarification there about proposed
development and having heard the agents
speak this morning
the applicants have had a preamp
where the principle
of development was accepted there is you
know something could be done there and
when you look at the photographs
um it is an eyesore right in the middle
of the village but more importantly for
me
you've got these heritage assets the war
memorial writing from the church right
behind and across the road you've got
that terrorism attached cottages
that the full application should come in
and i mean
whatever that application is then
if there are issues in there the
applicant doesn't like it's up the
applicant in negotiation with planning
officers to make it
as far as a planning officer can sort of
an acceptable application and then
whether it comes to us
for consideration or that is
is officer delegations in the matter but
the preamp did say
yeah the principle of development there
obviously and i i mean obviously
we could develop something there um
but we just don't know what it would
look like and it is important
the setting is very vital and i do agree
with what's at the top of page 116
that really it should have a full
planning application and then everybody
can inspect the villagers can look at it
and decide if it's acceptable our client
officers can
so it's been moved to
remove to agree with the recommendations
refused moved by councillor wiseman
setting
four
all right next application
the generation 70 is on page 127.
james jackson
james will give you a presentation on
this one
thank you good morning good morning
community members and good morning
members of the public watching on
youtube can everyone hear me okay
okay as it says on that first night it's
application one forward slash one two
five three four slash twenty twenty one
of course i check you out it's a
retrospective application for the
retention of the mobile home for
ancillary domestic use and the site of
west village and chiles river in
holsworthy
and just a quick verbal update before i
go on just for those benefit there are a
couple of references within the offices
report to
the council's five-year supply
position and just to clarify that
they're not that is not material to this
application so those references can be
disregarded by
by committee members today
next slide please strong
so this um on the on the left hand side
is the site location plan shows the red
line
including the area of land upon which
the caravan is sited and the private
driveway that leads to the public
highway over on on the western side the
blue line shows the applicant's
ownership um
stretches away there to the north
and also includes the applicant's
dwelling and existing annex which is
just down in the
um the southwest corner of
that slide there that picture just to
the to the left-hand side of the pond
um just to clarify the the mobile home
is sited approximately 20 meters away
from uh from their dwelling in annex
um over to the west we have the public
holloway and some former
um sort of disused fairly dilapidated
agricultural buildings
and some agricultural paddocks to the
north
uh just to the south of where the
caravan is cited shown in there the dash
outlines the two
dwellings that are currently being
constructed
in accordance with an outline permission
and reserve matters approval previously
granted
uh and over to the southeast we have a
two
two um third-party dwellings
and then the uh the aerial image on the
on the right just shows uh the
like that sort of layout and from from
our next slide visual
uh this just shows the site in the
context of the chills where the
development boundaries that might be for
commanders to see how it relates to the
uh defined
settlement children is designated as a
village within the local plan uh and
there we can see um the site there uh
and its proximity to
uh the western edge of chillsworthy
development
uh next location
this is just a photograph the one on the
left-hand side is the
mobile home obviously with an area of
decking
uh behind that is the fence line which
is the applicant's boundary
with a
stand of
mature trees and then beyond that you
can just see the roof lines of the two
dwellings that are currently being
constructed
uh the two photographs on the right hand
side show
the um
just the internal layout of the camera
the mobile home as usual really a
kitchen and lounge area two small
bedrooms in the bathroom
that's slightly sure
this slide just shows mobile home from
the private driveway this is down by the
access to the site
just on the right hand side of that
left-hand photograph you can just see
the edge of the applicant's dwelling in
annex
that's shown in front
on the image on the right-hand side so
you just get an idea of
the relationship between the mobile home
and and the entrepreneurs dwell in that
and look slightly sure
the photograph on the left just shows
the relationship between the mobile home
and the boundary
fence behind it on the right hand side
at the shot of the two dwellings um
currently being constructed
um the right upper photograph
is a view looking north from the decking
of the mobile home that's on the land
within the african ownership
and then the bottom right photograph is
a photo from just outside the access on
the public highway that would be the
only public publicly accessible point of
the mobile home and you can see it there
just above above the gates there
next slide official
um suggest a proposed amendment to
your suggested conditions from your
officer
this is just really just to um
clarify that obviously the the mobile
home meets the definition of a
caravan and therefore isn't development
in terms of the planning system
so there's just an addition involved
there just to
give the local flying authority control
over any replacement caravan in its
appearance so
um the the purpose of the condition
really is to ensure
uh that there is a scheme either for the
painting or the padding of the caravan
just to sort of reduce its stark
appearance somewhat in terms of
its appearance on the site
um and so that will ensure in your
office's view that
there's a more appropriate appearance
for the mobile home
and it's slightly sure
so the two considerations that are
relevant to this application
principle of development so the local
plan policy dm 25 requires that
annex accommodation be attached to the
main dwelling in this instance it isn't
and therefore is a departure from the
local plan and it's contrary to
um to that policy requirement
uh that that obviously means that
it
is the principle of development is
unacceptable um in your office's view
there is there are other material
considerations to be taken into account
here
uh there's a rural business run from the
site
by the applicants which is a small scale
dog grooming and dog breeding business
and so the
mobile home assists with that business
in terms of
providing a separation area for the dogs
when they're in season or in fact
they're injured or sick or anything like
that that's a requirement of
the license that has been granted by
tdc for
for the uh for the mobile home for that
business
um it it's also used by the
mrs harris the applicant's parents
uh a few times a year generally in
school holidays when they come and stay
and that also has a benefit to the
business in terms of their parents are
able to provide child care which allows
the applicants to focus on the business
more and they also do contribute to the
to the sort of business tasks of um of
the dog grooming and dog
dog breeding business as well
so the local plan does support small
scale economic development in the
countryside where it's well related to
defined settlements in this case the
officers consider that it is because of
its relationship to the chills within
the development boundary
there's also a modest social benefit due
to the cohesion of
allowing enabling family members to
spend time together
um and also
there's an absence of any environmental
harm in in this case as well so
in terms of the character and appearance
of the site as i've sort of said in the
in the presentation really it it's not
visible um from any surrounding
viewpoints other than
um a slight sort of visibility from the
access from on the public highway and
there's obviously the condition that's
suggested in terms of the painting or
cladding
of the mobile home which in your
office's view would would mean that
that's acceptable
uh in highways terms there's no
significant increase it's an annex
accommodation and visibility at the
the access to the site is generally good
uh in residential amenities there's one
objection from a nearby occupier which
is a third party dwelling over to the
southeast
uh a site visit's been made to that
property you can you can barely see the
roof of the
mobile home from his property
um and obviously it's a single story
form in terms of the mobile home so
there's no issue with it in terms of
being overbearing and viewed from
surrounding properties or anything like
that
obviously dogs are kept in that mobile
home at certain points during the year
but as i said the the business is very
small scale it's poor dogs effectively
and then any impact from that wouldn't
be dissimilar to what you might expect
from a residential use in terms of dogs
being kept
as pets or something like that
and biodiversity
there's just a precautionary really
condition suggested in terms of external
lighting
drainage minimal increase in impervious
surfaces so it's not going to increase
flood risk
and
the mobile home is connected to an
existing
sewage treatment plant
and they just don't know the matters
really it's just just um uh
advice to committee
it's obviously submitted on a
retrospective basis um but it doesn't
need to be considered sort of as any
other application really in terms of its
merits and
in terms of its material considerations
that relate to the application really so
the fact that it is submitted on a
retrospective basis is not material to
committee's um consideration today so
in conclusion really it doesn't
obviously accord with with the
development plan it's contrary to policy
dm25 that brings it into conflict with
the plan as a whole uh and it's a
departure from the development plan
and as i said really there are other
material considerations in in this case
that have set out
in your offices you do justify departure
from the development plan policy in this
instance
and i think if we look at the
sort of three strands of sustainable
development that's set out in the mpps
we have an economic strangle that
there's a benefit there in terms of the
applicant's rural business and how it
contributes to that
as a modest social benefit in terms of
social cohesion and in terms of
environmental there's no demonstrable
harm as a result of the application
and accordingly it's recommended for
approval
thank you
for saying questions
[Music]
thank you james
we've got two speakers to this
application so
our first speaker to the application is
jody harris
thank you once you settle you've got
three minutes to present to the
committee
thank you thank you
i know i don't really need to say if i'm
it's bothering me that people think that
i tried to obviously break the law by
putting it there without getting
permission but
i kind of spoke to
um two officers during the course of the
time so we moved in in december 2016 and
i put the caravan there in january 2017.
the caravan was placed on site so my
parents could visit the groom
we had a visit from an enforcement
officer in 2019 that was nigel marshall
and he stated that no further action the
caravan could stay so as far as i was
aware it was perfectly fine
i asked permission for enforcement
officer darren bird on the 24th february
2020 to change it for the one that it is
now and it was granted
and i obviously have the proof to show
you if you need to see it um
for us it's really important um a for me
to be able to work from home and i have
bipolar so i struggle with
within with this in general i suppose
and so having the dogs and having my
parents being able to visit is really
important and so it covers obviously my
licensing issues in regards to
um
being able to do the breeding and stuff
we planted over 2 000 hedging plants and
trees um by ourselves this year
and we've installed a devon bank and
also we've planted trees and hedging all
the way up the driveway both sides
conifers and either side of the caravan
so eventually they're going to grow and
kind of shield it off from everybody
anyway
and we've installed bird boxes back
boxes and we've also got a two-acre
national trust project going ahead this
year and one of our other fields to
encourage wildlife and
i kind of i suggested the cladding but
looking into it it's like six thousand
pounds so i wondered if painting
could be a better option for us um to
retain it and
that's all i really have to say
thank you
okay thank you thank you for that
and our final speaker this morning
is comes the hebel
award member
good morning
i'm obviously here on
on behalf of uh primarily the halls of
the hamlet's parish council who have
serious concerns about this application
and also other concerned neighbours um
[Music]
i suppose
in a wider sense i'm representing the
concerns of um
probably all of the parish councils
within torrenting as much that
there is
a concern about
how
planning is allowed to occur by stealth
and and
not following full planning policies
um
[Music]
i have a problem with the case officers
report um i i cannot understand why in
the
um
relevant history there is no reference
to the planning consent that was granted
on land that was part of westfield
the two
dwellings
under construction at the moment one of
which backs on to
the mobile home directly
i would have thought that relevant
history would have included um the
enforcement
issues
but maybe i'm incorrect in this
[Music]
enforcement
is potential from the public domain
because if there are ongoing issues it
could be used as evidence
okay thank you
the
case officer's reasons for
recommending approval um
just listen to
the case of positions now and apparently
the fourth reason the lack of a
five-year
housing plan has been withdrawn well i'm
pleased because i don't think torrid
should be seen to be using that as a
reason for
approving
an application
um
reasons one to three i would suggest on
behalf of paulsworthy hamilton's parish
council are tenuous
uh and the
fourth
observation i have there's been no
engagement with me as world councillor
throughout this by playing officer
and i thought that that was the due
process
my concern is if this is
if you vote to
approve this application
what sort of messages does that send
down to
um
[Music]
other parish councils
hold for the parish council and
council tax payers
but also it sends out a dangerous
message i think to anybody who has
ambitions to
circumvent the existing planning
policies
and what is to stop anybody
um piggybacking this circumstances
around this application and
eventually getting consent to
put up a mobile home that should not be
there
so
i suppose in in summary i would urge you
to think very carefully before you
follow the case officer's recommendation
to approve this
and consider seriously the implications
that that might have for future
planning applications of a similar ilk
thank you for having me
i just made one comment though that it's
not for the planning officers to inform
ward members about applications
in your ward any application we will get
the list of applications every monday
and
i is a boring memory and i'm sure the
rest of
the council
look at first and foremost you look at
what's in your ward if you've any issues
with that that's when you
approach the planning department for any
clarification but it's not for the
officer
in in in this case to come to you with
any
anything
right okay that's the end
[Music]
um
we saw the fence at the back of the
caravan and we told there are two houses
being built just beyond the fence one
one's quite close yeah
was this on land that was part of the
farm that's been sold off or was it a
completely separate development
what which you mean i know all about
this
sorry
you've got the caramel
you've got the caravan there at the back
you've got that wooden fence with the
two new houses behind
was that one part of the land yeah this
farm yes that's that's correct cancer it
was part of the site yes
right because
it does worry me that
apparently
i had to smile when i heard that
you know the mother-in-law comes here
i'm not sure if my mother or
mother-in-law comes in and other times
it's used with dogs
and you think
i'm sorry but i've had lots of
complaints as i spent many of us had
about dog barking with my neighbors and
it does seem very close
to that house behind
um i heard the planet earth to say
there's only ever four dogs there i mean
i don't have a problem a big problem
with this but having said that
if this is allowed to go ahead i think
we want to put condition on that there
is only ever
that number of dogs because these can
get out of control we've had this before
we get more and more dogs come in um you
know
there's a potential
for a neighbor dispute there which uh
i'm sure the council that wouldn't want
that
check can i just comment on that on that
point
so i'll tell you quite certainly there's
[Music]
there's two things really from the
officer's point of view one one is that
um any surrounding neighbors would still
have uh reports to statutory noise
nuisance in terms of environmental harm
so that but
if if committees were to find a
successful ground commission then that
doesn't obviously preclude anybody from
making those complaints and and secondly
really
there would become a point where the
where that business is going to tip the
balance for a change of use case law
suggests that that balance is usually
six dogs where it's a matter of
fracturing degree and so we would have
the ability to control that through the
padding system in terms of if if that
was increased then there is going to be
a need for pain permission
when i read this it is actually said
that one of the businesses is dog
breeding this isn't you know just your
own dog barking so there is a potential
here for this i i hear what you say but
i'd like to put it on as a condition
because
there is
we've had this before we've had at
heartland where you know recalled huge
number of dogs over time you know the
numbers grew the neighbors for years
they tried to get that tackled
and because the noise isn't continuous
it's quite difficult to take enforcement
with continuous noise it's easy to
measure this is one of the problems with
dogs
and i i'd like a condition but honestly
this is going to be passed but that's
only my question
for me for me reading through reading
through
this this is a licensed business tourist
licenses business
and i'm sure there are certain controls
through the license that apply to the
site
uh it's a small rural business
i know it's retrospective but
from what the applicant said when this
fall it seems you've had advice in the
past they don't need any planning no
they do need planning
they're going to camouflage it because i
have really really got no problem with
it
um yeah listen to what everyone said i
actually do have a problem with this um
looking at i know it comes under the
definition of a caravan but it is a very
very nice moma home
and if a farmer wanted to put that in
the field to support his business he
would have to
reduce three years of you know
accounts to say that he had a viable
business and it just seems to be wrong
that and there's so many if you read the
statement of reasoning to retain the
caravan which is on the website all
those reasons appertain purely to the
license
um and i don't see i was going to
mention about the 5 year land supply
because i mean that just didn't fit in
at all
um
but then it doesn't accord with dm 84
the mppf which states
um
sustainable growth and expansion of all
types of businesses in rural areas both
through the conversion of existing
buildings and well-designed new
buildings well that doesn't fit in this
mobile home
and also the development and
diversification of agriculture i don't
think dog breeding comes under the
definition of agriculture
so i am going to recommend reviews with
the applications on the grounds that it
does not call with policy gm 25 or dm 84
then ppf
check let's make a quick comment on that
one please just
in terms of the
dog reading obviously clearly that's not
that's not within the definition of
agriculture that's fine but as i sort of
explained during the presentation we do
have policy
which supports small-scale economic
development in rural areas um and it
does broadly meet those those criteria
so from your office's point of view it
is scientifically given way um i accept
that the the
um criteria are different for uh
for farmer accommodation and things like
that and agricultural development but
that's that's not what we're looking
here in terms of this proposal so
in your offices
that's a separate issue
[Music]
i mean
the planning offices for me made and
it's in
they had very good reasons other
material reasons
to recommend that we grant permission
for this and it isn't all that long when
all said and done five years ten years
it might be moving by what we needed
there but i really
we've always tried to support small
rural businesses always have them in the
planning
and i think it'd be a great shame to
refuse this but that's my view
anybody else like to comment yeah
yeah uh
since if mobile has been there there's
always been problems in chills with
the council
the
ambulance council
have had numerous complaints
about uh
for them to try to do something
it's situated there there i mean there
was a real
battle on to get those the houses at the
back of it or on the front of it
and
now the fence is round
you can actually if you if you look at
the back back of this mobile overnight
there's windows that overlook those the
people's gardens
which then you know and they're not um
they're not there for for
to be blocked off or anything and i
don't know what the planning was for
actually but i don't understand why why
they want to declare it
camouflaged
yeah yeah but but are the windows will
the windows still stay in the back of it
that overlook the gardens for those who
them through new properties
um
no i i'm sorry i
i know the ambulance of
about hellish time over this one from
other members of the public
and so i i'm going to agree with
councillor lock our
second that is refused
anybody else that comment on this one
can't you create this thank you i'd just
like to support your proposal i don't
think it's important that we have royal
businesses
to keep going you know
as you
i mean there's only been one letter of
objection come into this so i don't know
how many people in the children that
they should
raise any issues at all
if nobody else wants to we've got one
proposal a minute and that's to refuse
that i'll move that we do
approve it but we'll take um
we'll take the proposal to refuse it
first i'm going to take the vote on that
yes thank you chair
[Music]
for councillor mcgough against
councillor watson
hence the wise man
that's three
four
refusal
and six against refusal thank you
chandra now i've moved to approve this
to go with the granted permission
council craig is sending it councilman's
goal
secretary clinton
did it
can i just confirm whether that was
christie's additional condition or
i would not an addition but on the
number of
dogs in that caravan is limited to four
at any one time i think that's what the
officers
told us
yes that's right yes
[Music]
yes the amended condition in terms of
yes
three or three yeah
[Music]
yeah in in terms of cancer christie's
suggested condition would you be happy
for that to be delegated
[Music]
yeah okay thank you
uh councillor bento before
pence lebron
chancellor christie or
councillor craigie or
councilman leather
councillor lot against
councillor mcgrath four
councillor watson again council the wise
men
that's seven four and two against chair
2000
is care of the district council do we
have to declare an interest is it sorry
it's a very old word
[Music]
or just take five minutes or a couple of
minutes
comfortably cancel the grass
let's see
[Music]
okay everybody thank you thank you sarah
sarah chuckles here to give us a
presentation
this is going to be good do we have to
declare an interest or not
well it's a challenging application for
encouragement
cancel the brownies
we don't have to declare an interest on
this deal
i'm just going to pick up the reason
i've chosen those words quite carefully
that um it is in the care of the local
authority and the reason sorry can't
hear you oh sorry
try and put it right you've got to speak
right into the end of it
normally i'm loud enough for that
the reason i chose the words that it's
in the care of the local authority
was because actually we are the
custodians of these buildings um i'm
misquoting william morris willfully here
so we are the custodians of these
buildings and we must pass them on to
obviously the future generations it's
our duty and as a result i'm sitting
here because obviously it is a local
authority application and we are
obviously in the care we have the care
of this building in torrington
so if i could um ask for some slides to
come up and it's the market hall in
torrington as opposed to the town hall
they're separate beings
it's located on the south side of the
market square and it's very a very very
visible building if you can go on
i'm hoping that i put some interesting
photographs there we are we have an old
photograph of the
property which is the tower with the the
property with the velcro and we have a
more recent photograph of the property
you can see how nicely the conservation
area and list of buildings in great
torrington have preserved
the town center
um it is that bell cod that you can see
which is the subject of the application
and also
the decorative scheme on the frontage
uh the black and white photograph
obviously doesn't show you the color of
the decorative scheme but it does show
the tone of the decorative scheme in
place at that point
i've borrowed this photograph from the
beefid archive so thank you to them
[Music]
just some interesting photographs
showing how the bell cup has
deteriorated
and pass our thanks to the
the managers of the museum who pointed
out that it was getting very serious
so much so that our property department
mr berryman was able to remove it before
the latest round of storms and prevent
any additional damage to the
building or surrounding buildings or
people
as it's a local authority application
and we have actually
asked for plans to be prepared by
an agent
and the plans i have to say are very
clear i've reproduced them here they're
extremely nice plans and we're also very
lucky that they've done a paint
investigation which is quite a rarity
and extremely nice to have as an
addition to our understanding of the
building
and
you can see that the uprights have
deteriorated and they need replacing um
very kindly the
repairs are shown in green here so there
are elements that can be retrieved
and the bell cuts will be replaced as
previously
on the building
so
i thought i'd put a couple of
photographs in showing you
that the frontage of the market hall
looks a little bit undressed at the
moment without its
balcott
and also you can notice the
state of the decorative scheme
again
so as part of the
[Music]
proposal that we're considering um
they the
paint
investigation has shown that there have
been numerous decorative schemes over
the years and to stick to the one that's
currently there isn't necessarily
needed we can actually
look back and be informed by previous
schemes so
they have actually
marked on here a new decorative scheme
which is
slightly less
garish
if you'd like to move on
i have cleared this slide with my boss i
thought at this point in time you might
all be a little overwhelmed with
previous reports but it's played into my
hands today you're nice and fresh this
is something we very rarely see so i've
put it in this is a slide from the paint
analysis
and it says on the top what it is sample
four is taken from the frontage
and sample two is taken from the column
of bellcott so we can see all the
particular
color schemes very nicely put on there
for us i particularly withdraw your
attention to the grass green color
scheme from the 1960s which i'm
extremely pleased we painted over
um
it was obviously a devon county council
standard issue
paint at that time i seem to remember it
in schools
and
being informed by this and having this
information now to lodge with the
ongoing history of the building and
it's obviously i would suggest that the
colour scheme they're proposing which is
more muted
is quite in line with previous colour
schemes
and so i don't have any particular
problem with a different colour scheme
that is there
and
as it's fairly straightforward i would
recommend that we support the proposals
we've been extremely fortunate in the
clarity of the information given
and
i would ask members to consider it as
put forward yeah
fine
lucky sheriff
[Music]
it was great that the actual bell tower
would seem to be in such a
dreadful situation happening before
those high winds because it would have
caused considerable damage
so um i welcome the group to be joined
here thank you
thank you
have a second
thanks for watching you're sending it
okay i've just got one query um
839 the top
have paragraph that the black cast iron
gates the entrance and family market are
repaired not just painted i assume this
works not included in this application
but it's not mentioned anywhere i
haven't mentioned it because if if that
comes forward because um i've
overstepping my mind here i think there
are budgetary restraints and i will be
accepting whatever work we can get if
this comes forward the work that they
would be asking for i think we would
consider as works of repair and
maintenance that don't overstep that
definition and so it wouldn't require a
commission on its own
ok
but it's been a considerable worry
actually
to the town and to the town council
because those gates
are loose
very difficult hanging on a thread
almost and if they fell
they would then collapse a car with an
only person that's the reason we asked
about the gates they are in desperate
need or compare
thank you well
thanks so cancer ground for that but
that's not the end part of the
application
it's been moved by councillor brown to
ground this second place
was watching
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
applications
so the gender item eight is the appeal
decision somewhere on pages 24247
[Music]
and we've got the inspector's
decision there
right
item
nine on the agenda is cost some appears
there are no costs on stevens
10
is the delegated decisions a g and b on
pages
on page 148
for noting
item 11 on the agenda on the planning
decisions granted
between the 20th of january
and
[Music]
150
161
152
153
you'll be disappointed this one
154
150 556
[Music]
level um
this never came to the town council i
chair the town council planning
committee we never had this one and i
looked at the application it doesn't say
why it doesn't say anything about
replanting it just says we want to chop
them down
do we do we just say oh yeah no problem
i mean it isn't right in the town centre
they're very visible
looking through these i noticed that
when i thought which cherry trees are
there in the yard
if you've got the pork memorial yeah
there's two areas of grassland
yeah on the left either side of the
entrance to the
orders they belong to them well i didn't
know that i thought i thought we mowed
that area actually so
if they're claiming they own them that's
interesting
but why were they chopped down but no
reason was given why they should be
chopped down i don't know details
for a second
there's only three documents one's a
photograph and
there's no three officers report or
anything and they didn't come to the
town
you know someone will get some
information here on that council
christian
we're seeking to put some end down
right 100
page 160
well sorry 159 you've got the refused
ones at the bottom there and page 160
you've got not making
yeah
right thank you very much item 12
isn't it item 13 the 12th session
[Music]
and all those involved with the meeting
thank you all very much
and i declare the meeting
[Music]